what is it mr. cop mr. coffin has been
what 10 years almost it's been seven
years oh man you know what I I this
morning with my wife that I said I'm
talking to moment and of course she
doesn't know who you are right so I said
I got you so I gotta show you this guy
so I went and found a bunch of your
videos where you walk into a store and
you speak Khmer and Vietnamese and then
was where you talk to some Chinese guy
his foot oh I got to be looking at my
phone here and that spoke to this
Chinese guy I think in a restaurant and
you spoke to him in Russia and he said
no you're not speaking Russian oh oh oh
that was oh yeah that was crazy yeah
yeah so very impressive very impressive
so what has what has changed over these
last seven years not much man just um I
mean I live in Arizona now I don't I
don't live in Ohio so that's the biggest
thing that's different here I'm still
doing a language you know as usual I
can't I can't stop doing languages right
that's I should you know for those I
should say maybe some of my viewers
don't know who you okay although you are
a legend you're a legend
and we would like you to your unit you
know I'll link to your YouTube channel
in the description bar okay and I mean
you have massive numbers of subscribers
I don't know what it is 800,000 or
something yes like I think it's like
nine hundred fifty thousand and I don't
know how to happen I don't know where
these people came from I was shocked I'm
still shocked cuz I didn't really expect
it to that channel is there are people
you can say there are people like Lucca
who I think is phenomenal and you know a
limited number of languages so whatever
that is ten or something Moses is the
champ in terms of numbers of languages
numbers of unrelated languages so just
to go over that so I saw you speaking
Khmer and BA
and I should say that I went to Vietnam
and I tried to learn a bit before going
there and I was totally incapable of
saying anything other than come on which
is thank you
that's about as far as I got but you
also do could you just tell our people
who follow this channel just all the
different languages that you speak well
to what some degree like you don't have
to be a PhD in these yeah just that
you're able to a community longest
languages are Mandarin obviously English
that's my native language Japanese was a
Mandarin Japanese Cantonese Korean it's
up there Korean Spanish other languages
that I can it's so many of them okay so
so don't you do it so nyan or Georgia
oh okay so Estonian I'm not really doing
much of Estonian these days however I
study finished for a couple years
Georgian is one of them are manian do
you read I can read and write Georgian
read and write Armenian pretty much all
the languages I learned I know how to
read and write in them it's similar are
the writing system like to media look
the same Georgian and old air they use
the same well they're totally different
they're totally different yeah they're
very very different and I think that the
Georgian is probably easier to learn as
far as the writing is easier it's a bit
more easy to learn than Armenia but
they're they're very different languages
state the writing system is different I
mean they they both well countries a lot
of the people of both countries speak
Russian as a native language but though
they're that Armenian and Georgian very
different very very different yeah I
mean there you have a similar history in
a way you know early Christian countries
and the caucuses and stuffing and I
thought maybe I know the languages are
completely different like Armenian is a
European language right yeah it is I
know European yes whereas George is
something yeah Georgian you know what
Georgian the last time I read about
Jordan Jordan isn't is it's in his own
little group it's not related to any
other language this
that is an isolating language and it's
very unique like every I had a Georgian
I still do I have George and grammar
book every chapter literally every
chapter has a chart four four four four
what is it oh my goodness I'm forgetting
the word ear ear irregular verbs every
chapter they have a chart for irregular
verbs it's ridiculous you know we're
gonna get George link oh yeah okay okay
because somebody decided to translate
our many stories into George's so we're
gonna get Georgian I don't think we get
many people learning it but well but so
so showing geographically then so you're
you're into the Baltics and you can test
call to the edge yeah you know what it's
funny cuz Letha wainy and I just I know
you probably know that many years ago I
dad I dabble with a lot of different
languages Leif Delaney was one language
that I was dabbling with but just this
year last year I that's one of the
languages I decided to learn like four
times so leapt away knee isn't one of my
active languages right now you're in
Southeast Asia with Khmer Thai
Vietnamese yes you're in East Asia
with Korean Japanese and Mandarin and
Cantonese what other geographical area
I'm going to first Mendoza Sofia
Mongolian is over there too right yeah
monk so besides the East Asian we got
Southeast Asia we got right to Southeast
Asia then we have what else we have
didn't I see an Indian flag on one of
your videos oh yeah we have Indian
language is going on Tommy so I'm doing
Tamil full time now then I do Hindi I'm
not doing it full time but I do some
hindi here and there right a bit of
Punjabi what else is new you'd be
popular
oh man I heard about that yeah I heard
about that
yes yeah I have a quite a few Indian
language oh yeah yes so we got Somali
that's probably my strongest African
language Somali Swahili I'm hard easy
which is Ethiopian right okay yeah your
robot I saw your you said you're gonna
speak Sudanese Arabic but it sounded to
me like foot sir I could understand
everything yeah it's yeah it's food
that's another one of my current
activist languages Sudanese Arabic is
basically you know it's just a dialect
but they have their own words like
Shadid they say Shadid that that word is
for what it should be strong yeah yeah
like it's close to yes should be then it
they just have some words that are
different that only Sudanese people will
understand but for the most part if
you're for example if you're from Saudi
Arabia and I spoke to you in Sudanese
Arabic you will pretty much understand
even if there are some words that we use
that you don't understand you'll be able
to figure out what I'm saying from
context so it's you could speak that I
could speak that Sudanese Arabic with
anyone from the Arab speaking world yes
Zulu Zulu actually Swahili I think but
actually you know what Swahili is bond
to and Zul was more yummy they say yeah
it's a goonie language yoruba that's
Nigerian languages Nigeria and yeah I
had a friend at university yeah how much
American
in native languages what like Quechua
you speak I don't know catch no I don't
know that I Navajo is probably the one I
know the most but I'm interesting
learning like moose that Ojibwe Cree
would be a big one in camp which one
Cree Cree is though is most widely free
okay I've never heard of that really is
that CR EE uptick I've seen it correct
okay it's all across Canada all across
Canada I don't know how neutrally
intelligible all the different versions
of cream are but it's widely so you meet
them very often well I was involved in a
sawmill in northern Alberta and we had
there's a lot of people out there whose
be Cree and also we one of our partners
was a matey settlement and they speak
Korean oh yeah and there's Korean
British Columbia those Cree in Ontario
Quebec it's fairly widespread oh okay
yeah that's that's yeah I'm I have to
look into that Creek because I
definitely want to come back I went I've
been to Canada too
when maybe three times I've been in
Canada but that was Toronto but I would
love to go to Vancouver because I hear a
lot you know if you come to Vancouver
we will go do your yeah yes first of all
I've never done that but I've always
wondered like if you wander into a place
and you got your camera on like some
people don't want to be videoed right
and they don't want to be on the
internet like how do you get permission
or do you get permission after this um
whoa go chase you away
for the most part for the most part I
don't know how the laws are there in
Canada but here and particularly in the
United States you can record anywhere
freely except in someone's home if you
it's private so it has to be public so
normally when I when I do recordings I
don't really tell people unless state
the only time I tell them is if they
notice I'm recording now if they say hey
you're recording that's a camera then I
will tell them and then most of the time
99% of the time they're okay with the
date I'll tell them I have a YouTube
channel they say oh you have a YouTube
channel what's your YouTube channel
getting let me and I'll give them my
youtube channel
I had a couple times where someone said
yeah I don't want to be on YouTube and I
didn't use the footage but that rarely
happened to me so your camera is
actually you know what one second my bag
is right here so I have a hat I think
you've seen this hat before I have this
hat these are the cameras that I use
[Music]
okay so these are the cameras that I use
these are GoPro cameras I'm pretty sure
a lot of the lot of your followers a lot
of your viewers they know what GoPro is
so these I use these cameras GoPro and
what I do with these cameras is put it
I'll use this hat right so as you can
see as you can see there's a hole right
here
in this hat so I place the camera inside
of this you know like this right and you
can't really see you can't really you
know I'm six foot seven okay I'm six
foot seven so when I'm wearing this hat
most people can't really see even it's
funny because even when I sit down I
remember I was recording in a Chinese
restaurant and I was actually sitting
down I had this hat on and I'm looking
up at the waitress and she still didn't
realize that I was recording so most
most of time people are so intrigued and
interested in why I'm want to learn this
language they're not really look at this
and they'll just write you know they're
not really concerned about that but um
if they if you look at it if you if you
look if you keep looking at it you can
tell that it's a camera in there but you
have to be really looking so if you're
very observant --iv you will know it's a
camera and then you say wait a minute
what is they they'll ask you what what
is that what is
is that a camera so I had that happen to
me a Chinese actually a Chinese guy I
was in Walmart and I was in line talking
to him and his wife and then he was
looking he was looking at my hat and
then he said we he asked me Johnny so
what is that he said is that camera and
then I was like oh [ __ ] he I was like oh
man I gotta come up with a story so I
had to come up with some lip story I
said okay I said yes it's a camera and I
said it's my friend's birthday my friend
is having a birthday party tonight and
I'm recording the you know the reaction
and I'm record basically recording the
party and he's oh okay
okay and that was that but I used that
camera for that and then I have this I
recently just started using this here
this this just came out this is the max
this is the GoPro max now with this
obviously you know this is not going
into the Hat this is too big so I have a
chest strap i have the gopro chest strap
and basically what i do is have my
brother wear this and he's recording
from from his chest strap so so so the
viewers can see me which is better
really yeah because for for a long time
I've been recording in a way to where
you can't really see me you only hear me
and a lot of people they've been saying
oh we want to see we want to see you so
I said man I don't know how I'm gonna do
this and I say okay this is what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna get this chest strap
for my brother and then when I'm
practicing the language then he could be
recording from his perspective so and
you know it's that camera is exposed if
people look at them they can tell that
they look at they say they'll see that
he's recording but like I said before
they're so interested and why I'm
wanting to while I'm speaking this
language they're not really concerned
about their anyway so they're just
trying to see like why are you want to
learn this language will happen where'd
you learn why are you speaking it you
know
[Music]